as you know I am one of the producers on
your movie good boys those were vases
anyway you guys cannot watch the trailer
for your own movie what you're too young
boy we've seen your movies like super
bad you saw that movie it is not aged
well yes you filmed it before I black
people existed huh
I'm from Canada we've also seen sausage
party you saw sausage party
you made a cartoon that's on you dude
did you like it yeah it was okay I fell
asleep
well you know what I was gonna make some
calls and see what I could do but now
[ __ ] y'all
[Music]
more in sixth grade now we start doing
six grade things I know what cocaine s
get the [ __ ] out of your pee bag boys
only you little [ __ ] anipals been
watching Dateline she now knows what
cocaine is
hi let me be a beanbag boy I'll grow
tiny penis like Thor's tonight is our
first middle school party there's a big
girls there you know that means drama no
kissing I'm out I'm guessing you're not
the popular kids in school you do not
want to go to stores party not knowing
how to kiss hey stranger things go [ __ ]
yourself I have an idea I'm kissing are
you 18 or older the guy didn't even want
a kiss he was just licking a woman's
[ __ ] wanna kiss an [ __ ] Mack no
creature oh we could spy on my neighbor
she had told him then foaming yeah she
starts fires no she's a nymphomaniac
someone who has sex on land and sea this
is how we get the drone back you took my
bag oh my god there's Molly in there in
the forest it's a sex drug what if a box
seats hidden tries to [ __ ] a squirrel
it'll kill him no time to burn
everything
if you don't get to that party I'll stop
I'll just live here you guys are little
badasses [ __ ] us like kids between we
know how things work in north wing
are you Irish that swing is for sexing
people do sex on don't know a lot of
kids these parents of a CPR doll we can
practice kissing on that snap
you should never kiss someone without
their permission yeah I kiss you what do
you like about me sweet smell good
you're really pretty CPR doll I can sing
[Music]
you